here we go here we go it started I
wasn't ready for it I was just watching
a game and what do you know the cute
fanatic started and what do we know I'm
up there I loved there we had a quick
resigner to start double those points
and what will we have now no way a
back-to-back what is going on no way I
already have two three this train is
maxed out by the way average rating is
nearly 18 150 out of 150 d4 I was
considering f4 there the bird the bird I
was looking to go forward with Bishop
here okay there might still be just this
capture gonna damage my structure no I'm
ready to kick that bishop around could
be trapped if he's not taking the knight
my bishop I'm gonna take like this open
up that diagonal clean up pawn advance I
guess I chopped here first I was for a
second gonna do that that night was
gonna then kill me I get some play over
here actually King here get my knight on
f5 let's do this first I almost fell for
a for tricky tricky knight Knight right
here could be annoying that diagonal is
weakened now I could have taken that pun
I'm on it right now this is the idea
open this up I'm dropping this but maybe
it's okay
pile up on that pond he can't oh yeah he
could be defended he's not though
he is not being defended I'm gonna drop
back there's gonna be a check I block on
f3 with my Bishop I want to attack that
night a second time he's not being
attacked now there's there's that move
17 seconds okay do I have an advantage I
have two connected passed pawn rook here
this was pretty good in this end gamers
things gonna be okay
maybe I shouldn't have done that
my king is gonna get kicked around they
have a very good King position my pawns
are on light squares were they really
trade I have a king I've an advantage
because of the connected passed pawns
I'm gonna do this so I have a actually
I'm either down on time twelve ten nine
six six all right
okay can I be dynamic here
there's no matter what not quite okay
some type of tirage that diagonal is
open the bishop should probably get it
on there soon my bishop fiend keto and
get all my pieces working Queen c7 okay
that's a free pawn this one's falling
next it's a free night Knight takes here
nope there's two people on it now
two people let's take care if I take the
knight there'd be a pawn recapture my
knight is gonna have to run away and
there could be some sack on h7 so now
I'm looking to take the knight could
have also done this they're uh they're
spending a lot of time cleanup I get
this pawn push in if I could establish
two pawns here were the implications of
that it means that this Bishop is biting
on a rock not afraid of this rook just
yet
this Queen can't come out to any of
these three my knight as to my bishop
has the other one now I'll do this I'm
weakening my dark squares but I do have
my darks for a bishop around its be more
direct more direct
get my rooks in the center both of them
I don't want to commit either one yet
and time issue more than anything huh
six seconds I'm on the rook
anything really no time no time back to
German 30 John Madden slow down 30 18 17
12 12 12 okay
Pat Pat for short okay let's see let's
see
take here yeah okay this is not a okay
I spent - I did two steps there what is
my knight even doing
let's get Castle done we're gonna focus
on getting all my pieces out every game
every game get every piece working I
have this square covered Bishop could be
killed maybe right here I do this get
this on and get it get on this dog and
I'm looking to smash up in that
structure I have dark square control
looking to crash through there let's
stop night there I'm gonna take my
bishop to take my knight my knight wants
to be somewhere else or does he know if
I did 93 right away I think c5 would
have hurt me stop tonight here stuff get
my King offered the G file Nautilus open
I'm dropping that pond mate threat mate
threat this is dangerous
this is dangerous watching this there's
tricky Forks though not just yet
I want to kill that night would they
really miss this rook takes Knight now
if they're not missing that gotta go
fast or faster
I could um contest this file more
quickly a pile up on that pun really do
that oh no it would have been a bad
pre-move I need time burners where they
at
where are those time burners
time burners it's all I had Oh 42:36
2827 watch out for the time burners
there's a strategy to that get you keep
your rook active in short keep that rook
active keep your opponent's king
unstable my opponents not moving now
they are moving okay
f2 can I get it quick f2 strike Queen h4
I'm heading for H 2 H 2 or f2 I have an
eye on both watch out for b4 advance
although it gives this Square to the
knight now
yeah okay I'm not afraid of that one
though more afraid of Knight B 5 D 6
stuff on this pawn that's a bit awkward
that looks ugly doesn't it I don't want
them to get I don't want my opponent's
pieces to get in here
maybe Knight takes pawn is on I'm gonna
take it there could be capture here you
get the material back support my knight
even if he's captured that would mean
that the light-square bishop has to give
itself up I think pawn push is actually
good with an eventual skewer against the
Queen let's take this guy out let's do
it right now Queen takes pawn here I'm
on the bishop first so this is what I
was talking about Queen takes bishop
here could get on this diagonal I'm fine
with giving back that material this is
what I was talking about now the rook is
dead do I have anything better than
taking the rook could take the pawn on
see to it at some point
15 seconds to 27 no rush just yet maybe
I could hit a and go with the fork let's
do that keep my light square Bishop
round
and I got rid of theirs now my queen is
here hitting the night no it's not
let's deflect the Queen away from the
defense of the night there's no time
back to tournament 56
no yeah 56 40 39 already 21 minutes
remaining
uh-oh uh-oh this one's not starting
could get a quick win
who's playing top game John Madden come
on team black come on black don't mob
like you got this Harry Potter let's go
Harry Potter use some use some tactics
here some magic show your magic show
your magic 47 seconds Oh 33 seconds john
madden is fast though it's fast nothing
here just yet material is even the back
rank issues though nothing in my game
yet hit me with the error let's go a lot
of pressure
oh no dead down on a minor piece John
mans up a minor piece this is a problem
everything is hit the whole farm is
falling okay
err err err err give me air and give me
points what did I get I got some points
John man's gonna win that game we could
have been paired up actually I was
around the same time that both games
ended his match the cob Sicilian
apparently okay
so far so book night D or Bishop g4 ship
G kicked this night out of their first
stop Knight c4 I'll go with this it's
more dynamic more dynamic okay I don't
care about my my beep on get play on the
dark squares
right my knight could fall there's night
checks clean here I would meet with f5
there's still let's do this I'm on the
rook now I don't even know if I want to
take it no I like my darks for a bishop
too much I like that because it's a free
night
he's a freebie ok let's take him out
first and now I have some tricky tricky
discoveries no getting some more
material more material King here rook g8
I could take the bishop
I could take that rook this rook
everything is falling
it's just soon to be me the Queen us to
give itself up soon they resigned back
to tournament 72 60-56
18 minutes remaining ok efore alright
let's try some gambit I'm not gonna go
in for the for the what okay that can't
be right opening up this dog on my
bishops gonna play to c4 very soon and
it's gonna be difficult to castle my
queen is in a good spot queenside castle
since the D file is open no actually
maybe not I mean I could stand the a
file okay that's trouble meeting one no
getting run away here it's got to be
scary though it's got to be a little
scary get that night here get him out of
get him out of my house
I'm the queen and this point soon on
this point Queen c42 here this is close
to mate now very close to me where is it
where is that mate night here first
night here first and then clean to one
of these two just watch over this square
they're not moving ah night oh ok well
it's still controlled Queen here Queen
here next it looks good
doctor tournament 1976 72-68 17 minutes
remaining
give me your queen watch out for the
Queen's my bone is gonna go all in for
my queen here or maybe not yeah they are
alright they're gonna move I mean all
right let's grab some space and now I
have
there's no drawbacks with this variation
let's keep my knight on the board that
can't be right
no way I'm gonna take that guy it's
Castle I have cool check stuff Queen
check is soon to be happening here I
don't want to Queen trade their King is
more vulnerable
um actually the Queen trade is gonna
happen isn't it what can you do I have
this fork maybe the knight has to play
to a3 now I'm getting that I'm not
taking this Queen she's pinned first
maybe there's something more yeah this
looks good and that has to block I feel
like I don't want to just take that
night I'm going to we could get a mate
like you made some Queen here to here
King here mate in two on this square
eight and one and then two doctor
tournament 110 ninety four ninety sixty
eight sixteen minutes remaining
okay that Bishop out and strike at this
point there is Knight takes pawn how
kinda we're not having that looking to
open up the F file and then pinpoint f7
get some play on the a file if the
bishop is taken okay oh my bishops hit I
can move my knight and be hitting their
Queen Queen trade take with this rough I
know this one hmm
let's take this my knight could be now I
should have just done that my knight is
very dangerous no very dangerous and
keep the Queen's on the board
she can't be too comfortable here I'm
gonna get a seven again it's happened in
the last game or one of those games mate
threat on a8 made threat still in a
eight also mate soon the King tries to
run I get the rook with check and then
it's got to be me
very soon not moving 14 minutes
remaining in this tournament
oh that's check
okay that stops the me for just a moment
let's get another check where's this
King going to go
he's running here no matter what another
mate threat right here is the threat
rook block I give check and then mate
next they resigned back determinant 110
or no 114 110 110 I have a lead but just
by a little bit there's two guys up
there who could already have won a game
and now been in the lead so let's go for
this setup okay winning upon but but I
have a backward deep on so how do I
address that I want to get in d6 I'm
okay with this I'm still okay I would
have been okay on Castle now I'm gonna
take that in pinpoint the weak pawn here
it's not being defended but I'll watch
over d5 here no matter what
get on the c8 square there could be some
sacrifice here I don't care about this
pawn okay I'm definitely open to trades
on the night at the end of this let's
watch over this now if I did this
there's rook takes pawn Oh why'd I do
that okay mate threats defend my seventh
and get my King closer to the center
actually this I think is good and then
just March my pawn keep going
can't be stopped the king should have
come over towards the center right they
resigned back to tournament 140 134 130
86 both of these guys have given me
beatings before Dylan and John Madden
alright let's go with this and this no
matter what and close to this I want to
get an e5 that's one of those half
developing moves off the back rank but
nothing more than that Bishop g4 would
have been better so I have rapid
development can cake this night away I'm
gonna set up something sneaky maybe if
they Castle pawn push and then the Greek
gift sacrifice we're soon to be seeing
that okay we're going to be seeing that
Bishop takes here followed by a knight
here no matter what even if King h8 if
it takes I recaptured the pond and then
my rook comes to life this is close to
be me if this pawn moves I played g6
living mage made on h8 if the rook moves
I take the pawn and then check on H 5 H
8 and then or just H 7 back to
tournament 161 160 161 54 Oh big game
big game the game oh we're gonna have
the Smith Mora my opponent I'm sure is
well aware of age too I wonder if
they're nervous I'm still coming at I
still come enough that age to square the
dark square Bishop Oh are they fearing
age too are they nervous they nervous
take him he's free he's free ok let's
come back I have to watch over this now
I'm in big trouble big trouble now I'm
in big trouble
to watch over this afternoon Knight
takes I need this covered oh boy this is
scary I feel like there's me my bishop
doing something he wasn't doing
something good there was he bad push ok
now maybe I can at least jump it to this
square I have to give up some material
they take that I get into this F for
square they're down on a lot of time
jump in here ok take like this jump in
here next that's where I want to be
definitely probably take that I want to
reinforce this and I guess just open
stuff up that rook is in a pin I'm not
gonna take it
well that's a free queen they're having
to fly because they're really down on
time here they have no time back to
tournament 174 that was a big win 174
158 158 oh they they ended up with the
speed bump those guys ended up I guess
dropping back ten minute warning 10
minute warning I didn't want to do that
wasn't expecting C 5 right this guy
gonna move yeah so the knight gets to
develop with the tempo drop that Queen
back stay out of this bishops way not
the most aggressive square on the
half-open file that Bishop isn't ideally
placed there need to spend additional
move to get my dark square Bishop out
pawn push maybe I can make something
happen here I'm looking to open it up
next bishop take stuff soon watch out
for the g2 square bishop move next let's
do this watch out for this dough Queen
here might be good that's a slick move
let's do that subject the Queen to some
issues maybe actually what am i doing
dropping material huh gotta watch over
that I'm opened up I've opened up this
diagonal let's just play back and now
maybe take here next get my queen
somewhere else I get my King off of this
diagonal that's what I should be doing
this game is taking forever
could have done that as well okay they
have dark square issues
dark square issues night here Queen
check I even know what that does Queen
takes pawn I get this Bishop can I move
my bishop and give check that's what I'm
looking to do next I'm on this square
twice
there's night forks rook here I have
this fork one of these works has to bump
up there that's the trick
okay back to tournament if King takes
then I take the pawn and give check and
I get the Queen on a2 194 178 178 144
keep doubling those points and moving
fast and hopefully winning all right
there's got to be somebody out there who
still doesn't know about h2 there's got
to be it's not this guy though Bishop
here pre-move dark square weakness is
still trade off that dark square Bishop
let's take a pit stop here first my
Knights gonna be a monster he's gonna be
a giant monster hello my queen on g5
Queen on g5 Queen on g5 and then there's
oh this is winning Knight here next
deadly fork exploiting a pin Queen here
and then pawn push probably no matter
what rook takes the lead to mate
right now we have a double check
followed by maid on h1 threat can't be
defended that's me right back to
tournament 214 198 176 164 less than 7
minutes remaining I'm stood still be
caught within one game somebody could
still get the 20 points French winner
are all right Fort Knox
not quite okay usually I don't know
about usually but I think pawn takes
happens quite a bit
instead of Queen takes the queen is dead
she's out of squares it's one of the
risks you run with recapture with the
Queen like that so there's two minor
pieces that they are at least getting in
return for that I'm on the rook maybe I
should have done this first
there was something to that I really
take this to opening up the position the
pond can't move just yet
not just yet a camo now it could but now
I still have more pressure on it I take
this on the night at the end of it you
know open up files actually f4 f5 next
to continue looking to sacrifice here I
could do that soon if I go here there's
night h4 chase this night away oh that's
a as a mouse slip threatening it again
I'll break down the dark squares let's
hang on hidden come all the way back
Rick f3 so I had some lateral movement I
get rid of this night next oh the rook
can take the pawn there's Queen check
and then capture here though counter
attacking and on I'll be able to get to
the nut at the night rook takes pawn
here feels right Oh didn't recapture
where's the mate look up and over
broke up and over I was gonna do Brooke
f3 to h3 next 238 238 234 5 minutes
remaining all if we get paired up it's
gonna be a big game very big game
where's that Queen gone
she's picking off the pond but I'm going
to look to open up this position let's
break down the center I want to open
things up when when I have what when
there is and there on castled would that
take so long to say pond push like push
the fork this night has to run away and
now there's some Greek gift stuff
happening now there's some Greek gift
stuff happening on each to Queen to one
of these two and I could take here but I
drop back and I still have discovered
check stuff let's drop back it's that
night still gonna be a pain night here
is available this King is still a little
uncomfortable he's got to be I'm not
moving let's do that I guess oh my queen
is trapped which is not Oh Queen here
Queen here's the threat
I get the night at least
watch h7 maybe I could get here and on
this rook not anymore
on the Queen light-square weaknesses by
my opponent can I take advantage
okay Queen trade okay I got the rook all
the Knights dead he's dead King marches
now not so fast
give that up
oh they're down on time I thought I was
down a time three minutes remaining two
52 to 54 ah if he wins that game I think
they might end up calling it soon oh
that would have been bad kick this night
away kick that night away on g7 castling
is probably suicidal to defend Bishop h6
on this rook I don't want to Queen trait
I need some quick wins get my Night Out
really take care just castle wow they
did take there oh they're just gonna
Castle now that Knight is actually too
annoying actually maybe I want a clean
trade No
yeah there's problems on g2 and watch
out for that I think it's safer here
spine could fall clean trade time
situation these guys playing a very
strong game I need to get my pieces
working my bishop is gluing everything
together
even with my age fine I want to be able
to take here so much for that keep going
with these keep going with those ponds
get a passed pawn soon keep my Brooks
active King position next King position
King position King position he
discovered tricks but that pawn is
pinned he's passed and then this guy's
passed next right less than 7
time time time time they resigned back
determine 298 I need a quick resign or
one minute remaining I think they called
it 298 274 236 ah
second place confetti 21 games in 18
games in 19 games in okay 298 274 - 36 -
24 all right good games